alright so that was President Donald
Trump there at the White House with
Attorney General William Bar and
commerce secretary Wilbur Ross talking
about an issuing of a new executive
order basically ordering all federal
departments and agencies to hand over
relevant data that they possess
piecemeal or not on who is in the
country legally and illegally citizen or
non citizen and this could come from
anywhere the Health and Human Services
Department USDA Social Security Treasury
it all goes to the Commerce Department
Greg which runs the census and now
they'll have a more accurate reading of
who is in the country legally as a
citizen and who is not so the Supreme
said no and he found another way using
previous available databases that is
about 90% accurate kind of what he said
it's almost exactly what Scott Adams
said yesterday that he was going to do
have to say that anyway here's the this
goes to the bigger question is and I
think the Democrats have to act
understand this this is America's
decision about our borders and our
citizenship not the rest of the world if
you ignore that question you're gonna
end up with brexit because breakfast
brexit happened when millions of British
citizens saw Germany's decision impact
their future immigration right and that
caused the fracture caused them to leave
the EU because they said with Germany's
going to let all these all these
refugees in they're gonna end up in
England so if government ceases to
enforce their borders America will end
up like the EU and States will have to
create their own long term solutions
right to impact security and well we get
a divorce are we going to work together
and I would rather see the country work
together than divorce over this all
right so the president said that he
needs this relevant information to make
informed public policy with regards to
immigration health care the Voting
Rights Act and also to deal with
congressional apportionment which is
going to be challenged come on you know
things like infrastructure also I
mentioned USDA just because that's where
if you are on food stamps for example or
your farm workers things like
I think from a legal issue the the
Commerce Department did not set this up
well initially and that's what led to
this legal jam that they were in and
what bill Barr the Attorney General just
said is that the impediment to adding
the question was a logistical one it's
not a legal one right he still maintains
that it would be legal to put it on
there but they're not gonna be able to
do that in time in order to do the
census so they had to take another route
but from a political standpoint I think
that President Trump would be in a
position to say well it's a win-win for
for me and for me he would say for
America because he's raised the issue
this question of isn't it common sense
to want to know yeah citizens are in the
country like and I'm trying to fight for
it and I'm trying to find a way to do it
the Democrats want to block me the
courts want to block me but I found
another way I'm doing everything that I
can so that he figures out a way to talk
about it on the trail he actually said
that the Democrats won are trying to
conceal the number of non-citizens in
the country well you went after the
courts he went after the left wing he
said they're trying to stop the Pledge
of Allegiance of Minnesota another total
lie but okay no it's not this is
ridiculous anyway okay well it's been
all over the news all day yeah and
apparently you've misinterpret because
all it is is a City Council in one city
that said you don't have to do it at the
start of a City Council nobody's banning
the Pledge of Allegiance but you get it
I get the idea that people are scare
mongering that's what this president is
doing Hillary Clinton said today this is
weaponizing fear and bigotry and I
couldn't agree more
it's a wiser iscariot I took what
Hillary is not a good thing I think
she's right why I tell you something the
Supreme Court of the United States said
no so he said yes they're including it
because knowing up to snuff it was just
a matter of an executive order Jesse he
would done this before no he went to the
Supreme Court they made their argument
to the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
said no he said did not say they did
Dressen they don't have time oh they
don't have time because they lost in the
Supreme Court and now in fact the census
is a responsibility of the Congress and
he is going around the Supreme Court
around the pound its responsibility of
the Commerce Department one no never the
question why is it scary to ask this
question because it intimidates people
who should be participating in our
census or my questions they ask they ask
you if you're in a same-sex marriage
they ask you if you were born in Puerto
Rico your age your race how you commute
to work how much you use the internet if
you're disabled are all those questions
scary it's such a fabricated
manufactured outrage and it's so
transparent and I I just disagree with
you respectfully Juan and to respond to
your points to Dana I think it's telling
that a justice Thomas's comment said he
in his separate opinion he basically
said look this is the court that's
doubting the sincerity of what is
otherwise an adequate rationale since
when do we invalidate agency decisions
based on that secondly don't forget that
speaker Pelosi is calling for a vote to
hold a G bar and the this the Secretary
of Commerce in criminal contempt for an
for failing to answer questions about
their internal discussions so when you
say that they're going around it I think
that's a utilization of resources
available to them that for some reason I
don't agree that we should remain these
inflexible boxes that the left keeps
trying to shove the administration into
final point let me restate all the way I
think it's interesting that many
countries have this question the UN
recommends it as practice actually and
yet for some reason when we bring it up
in a wave of changes that we often do
it's considered draconian okay so I just
wanted to respond to what you were
saying yes that in fact what we know is
that Republicans in fact the deceased
Republican donor came up with this idea
as a way to depress non-whites in the
country in terms of counting them for
purposes of indigenous from the 1820 no
no no yes they I'm just telling you that
this was part of the rationale being
employed by the Trump administration and
let me just
that is what happened that is what
happened I'm not but it can be tricky so
this weekend what the president now is
proposing is oh we're gonna have
immigrant raids this weekend oh yeah
illegal immigrants karyotyping I just
wanted you guys everybody so people who
have lived here ten years twenty years
their families together you think it's
okay then to have people knocking down
their doors separating killed yeah you
know you're okay with not knowing
anything about who's in the country
along so there if it's not a secret how
many illegal immigrants are in the about
12 million about 12 million offered ten
to throw on that what so the census has
done every ten years but there's this
other thing called the American
Community Survey on that American
Community Survey it does ask citizen
right so I don't understand why we're
having this fight it's because if they
if you ask people it could depress the
number of people in ingression 'old
istrict Curran by Democrats and there
might be a lot of Democrats there's a
lot of Democrats represent districts
that have a high illegal immigrant
population not all of them but some and
they're worried about a decrease in
power what is the end of Congress and it
decreases the kind of resources is this
individual that's right count the number
of people a non citizen is our county
hood yes you are County two people a non
citizen is also an individual or County
and
you just go out and count people and you
can put this the social nude notes no
generator no gender either we are
counting the people but there are
categories within the people there's
thousands of kueh these things exists
you can count the people and then ask
them that they're citizens or not they
don't intersect twice base later if
you're black they asked if you're born
in Puerto Rico or they asked if you're
Russian terrific
you can't ask you if you're a citizen
you can't skip they're a citizen you
guys that bastard here's the situation
people who are here illegally fear that
they would be not only what the door be
just busted down but they would then be
taken away either put in jail or thrown
out this is a threat to them and these
people are our neighbors and he's asked
is act as if they're come from out I
don't that's not they do the counting
people I don't think they're as scared
as you think they are okay as they're
walking around in broad daylight never -
I thought they fled these violent
countries in Central America I don't
think they're afraid of a questionnaire
okay actually they've been fleeing
violence in their own countries don't
you want me to get driver's licenses
yeah yeah one also don't forget a
driver's like the government does not
make decisions based on whether or not
someone might be scared of course that's
just not how the government about the
government should make a decision based
on our Constitution instead of having
executive I remember when people like
Obama dueling thinks through exact
matching now look at you Jesse you have
totally tiny new exec making Sue and
though they can be held up in
cooperation it's the case then you get
your guy bill bar back have him say
we're gonna go actually legal action I
think it's no it's it's unconstitutional
on cake around the Congo in the Colgate
one so if you're the president United
States you operate the executive branch
so all of these departments in these
agencies are under the executive branch
you can't call DHS or any these
Department say hey secretary can you
send over the data that you have you're
saying that's unconstitutional I'm
saying that's what he's doing what I
just said what I said that's exactly
what
Constitution says that the census is
under the authority of the Congress this
what you see from the Commerce
Department is the Commerce Department
actually operates but it's the Congress
that has this Authority the president is
now going around the courts around the
car to fire up his political base with
this kind of bigotry actually he's
officially doing something in the
executive branch what's wrong and it's
something that he promised and that he's
working on and in he's kind of laid it
out pretty clear it's a simple question
and it's a question that somehow how is
that how is that any worse than asking
your gender right that'd be scary right
well for me exactly well your race for
example is that's in the Constitution
you can ask there is but this is love
how long is a strict constructionist
yeah because you guys